the jurgen experience floyd's undefeated
too but he's not
the greatest boxer of all times right
it's arguable he is
it's arguable he is i don't think so
this is man i feel like he is he's my
favorite
he's been hit hard maybe four times this
whole [ __ ] car right you stop and
think about how many fights he fought
against
great elite guys not just great defense
like the best defense of all time yeah
you're talking about a guy who's fought
everybody he fought everybody he fought
canelo he fought pacquiao maybe he
didn't fight pacquiao when he was in his
prime
and maybe [ __ ] canelo when he was young
and made him cut extra weight he did
smart [ __ ] but at the end of the day
being a fighter though right
yeah at the end of the day the [ __ ]
guy is 50 and 50 well 49 and conor
mcgregor
that's what he is that's what i say this
is 49 yeah because it's kind of weird
yeah it's kind of weird somebody like
sugar ray robinson you know sugar ray
robin is different yeah
that's you know different time different
time
right yeah yeah but yeah he lost uh he
flossed 15
i think sugar ray robertson had
somewhere in the neighborhood of 90 plus
victories before his first defeat though
what is like how many
what's his first something his first
defeat was the
wasn't it the jack lamanna jake lamanna
jake
how old was he
i think he i think he beat him in the
decision in the first fight
and then robinson beat the [ __ ] out of
him in the second fight no no no no
really sugar ray robin they fought six
times they fought six times
and uh robertson knocked him out
robinson fought him
uh beat him at the first first time and
i think in the rematch
is when uh when uh lamada knocked him
out
knocked him out i don't remember that
and then and then the sixth fight
uh he tko'd jake
uh um yeah but it was a standing tko
yeah and he never you know he never got
knocked off of his feet right
that you know and he was you know
talking [ __ ] uh well you stopped me but
you didn't never
i never never put me down yeah that was
a
that was the saint valentine's day
massacre right yeah yeah when he went
through the ropes and he was
he's like leaning just getting yeah just
getting pounded on the ropes
yeah that guy had a ridiculous chin
crazy
eating shots like that from sugar ray
robinson yeah wasn't that at
middleweight two
and robinson really started off at 147.
yeah i think it was lighter
i think he started even lighter it was
40. 44
his record sugar ray robinson sugar ray
robertson
his record's like 200 and almost 200
fights
crazy that's crazy 250 something like
that how come we can't get that many
fights to mma
oh it's more than that well in boxing
his 200th fight
was a hunt well look at that 173 1986
against joey archer um that's his 200th
fight
go go back into his uh first loss or go
back to the jake lamoni fights you got
to go way back
stop um those are all win win
win win win jake lamanna so he beat him
at 36-00 and he lost
uh unanimous decision yeah that was
right
40 and then he beat him again unanimous
decision so he lost unanimous decision
to jake lamotta
and then he beat everybody else up into
a jaw a draw with jose barossa
basaro rather so he made it to 40 you
know
yeah i thought it was a lot more than
that so his 40 his 41st
fight he lost that was his first loss
and it was a decision at jake lamanna i
guess floyd really is a goat
i think he's the goat you know it's a
different era here's the thing it's like
you know when you look at mike tyson
when he was in
we just had this conversation yesterday
on the podcast but i think mike tyson in
his prime when he knocked out larry
holmes when he was
when he starched marvis frazier like
when he was just smashing everybody i
think
he had reached this level that you can
only maintain for a certain amount of
years
you know whether like i think the same
thing you could say before fedor
when he was was in his prime when he was
running things in pride yeah there's a
level that you could
reach that you can only maintain for a
certain amount of years and it's real
hard because
i think this is what i said yesterday i
think if muhammad ali
had been in the same era as mike tyson
he would have been better
because mike tyson was around you you
get better dependent upon who's around
you
and the when you're in an era you're
kind of defined by your competition
ali was defined by joe frazier and
defined by joe for
george foreman and and all the guys that
he fought ken norton
all those guys that he fought in his era
but there's it's a different era with
tyson it's a different area you're also
forgetting that he beat
yeah you know floyd uh floyd patterson
uh you know it's like before you know
like all the fights that he had before
he
you know came back you know but those
just weren't competitive right you know
he was so fast
he hit so hard you know beating sonny
liston you know something listens you
know he was a murderer back then yeah
he's
freaking killer yeah it's like he
destroyed floyd patterson twice yeah
twice in the first round right he was
he could you couldn't he couldn't get
hit by him you just couldn't get hit by
him yeah he had giant [ __ ] hands
you know a guy that was close close to
the mafia you know he's like
and uh yep so he beat all those guys you
know it's like
and yep you know it's like so maybe if
he doesn't have that three years off you
know maybe
maybe yeah maybe who knows but he did
and it's also
he was a different cultural figure right
because when you look at like his impact
on
society and civilization he stood for
something right he was a guy who was
like i'm not going and fighting this
[ __ ] war
it doesn't make any sense they took his
title away from him and the people loved
him
yeah it was it's a different well is it
different
about 50 of the population hated him
right and then fifty percent of the
population loved him and thought he was
the greatest thing ever yeah
and you know it's like i ain't going
over there to fight any viet cong they
didn't do anything to me
it's like uh you know it he's a very
very interesting
you know figure and then you got
somebody like uh
you know joe frazier you know you know
very very good fighter you know won the
olympic gold medal was an alternate
going into the olympics and uh and the
alternate you know
i forget what happened over there uh you
know he ended up not fighting joe fought
he won the olympic gold medal
they they actually rematched uh as pros
and then joe stopped in my fourth or
fifth round
wow and uh you know he was a beast you
know and then george foreman you know
it's like that's a guy that didn't ever
put on a pair of gloves until he was
i think 19 years old right that's crazy
you know it's like 19 years old think
about that there's just not that many
guys that have
you know it's never put on a pair of
gloves until they're 19 years old and
then get to that level
well that's the deante wilder story too
you know is it yeah dante wilder
boxed for a year and a half before he
won a bronze medal in the olympics
okay uh george foreman george foreman
won the
gold medal in the 70s you know when it's
like when it was
even i think harder you know to win the
gold medal because you because of the
cubans and the russians
you know it's like they because they
they never went pro and stuff like that
you had that right
uh phil stevenson right um and so it's
like i think it was a 76 olympics that
he won the gold medal
and he was like 24 fights as an amateur
that's all the fights he had never lost
that's nuts and it's like you know
just crazy uh he fought just 20 times as
an amateur before traveling to mexico
city for the 1988
1968 olympic games amazing you know and
never lost
and then so that it's like think about
that you know this guy's walking through
guys like joe frazier
and then he fights uh older muhammad ali
and you know and then gets you know
knocked out in the eighth you know it's
like
crazy you know he believed that he was
invincible you know he
you know arguably the hardest hitter
ever yeah you know it's like you know
what would have happened to mike tyson
we might not have known who mike tyson
was if he would have been around in
in those days you know who knows or mike
tyson would have smashed him yeah
you just don't know he was faster than
everybody the thing about mike tyson as
a
as a knockout fighter if you watch like
the marvis fraser fighter
i don't watch faster than muhammad ali
though i don't think he was faster
um muhammad's feet were so fast because
i don't think he was faster
you got to think back to you know when
he fought sonny liston when he thought
floyd you got to think about different
how his feet were then but the three
years afterwards i think he was faster
than when when he fought like when he
came back
do you think that mike tyson was faster
than that version of yeah i agree with
that
i agree with that yeah that's what i'm
saying yeah but ali
was a different animal like no one had
been around before him there was a
heavyweight that moved like that they
didn't exist well andy
no probably the best chin ever oh
amazing he wasn't that heavy for a
heavyweight though right no
no he fought he he the olympic gold
medal he won was cruiserweight
was it yeah he didn't fight with
heavyweight uh i mean yeah
he moved up to heavyweight for when he
turned pro
who was the english guy that knocked him
down and they cut his george uh
george no um yes
george was it george yeah it was george
george um trying to remember
he was uh a british gentleman who had a
really good left hook
and he caught him with a left hook and
yeah and had him in all kinds of trouble
and uh
then they they there was a tear in his
glove tear on his glove
george starts with an h if i remember
right
well he had a small little rip and uh
his
corner uh you know what's his trainer's
name
tore the grove a little bit yeah they
tried to find a pair of gloves and it
halted the action of the fight for about
five minutes and it gave muhammad ali
time to clear his head and then they
resumed the fight they never found
another pair of gloves to put on
on him in the middle of the rounds think
about this this is like wasn't it henry
something
yeah henry henry you're right cornering
henry cooper there it is there it is in
the corner yeah it was good cornering
and it's like and then he went out there
and he stopped him
yeah yeah he stopped him on cuts and i
don't remember if it was the next round
or
the following round yeah you know but he
cut really really easy they said they
had
uh his skin they just get bumped see if
he can find that fight
when henry cooper drops him because it's
crazy he hurts he's
but he's like but he he looks dead his
ass hits and he pops back up
you know it's like but it's like when
joe frazier when joe frazier dropped him
you know it's like his ass hit and and
he pops right back up he's crazy looks
dead
his chin was incredible catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience